Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass es euch gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann klickt auf den Link in der Beschreibung.
Dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So Leute, bin ich am Start.
Ich muss noch mal schnell aufs Klo.
Und was zu trinken holen.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Stunden
schon ein bisschen am Preis-Champ gebastelt.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht,
ich mache jetzt einfach Stream an.
Ich hatte heute leider nicht so viel Zeit,
etwas großartig zu machen.
Real-Life-Stells.
Megasack.
Dabei wollte ich mit dem M-Core
noch etwas aufnehmen, irgendwann die Woche.
Das Wochenende.
Habe ich jetzt gar nicht in Discord geguckt heute.
Und dann wollte ich mich ein bisschen
um Sellout-Stunks-Zeug kümmern.
Dass ich da ein bisschen
Sellout-Money hinkriege wieder.
Wow, ein bisschen groß.
Kack-Wait.
Ja, ich habe den M-Core angeschrieben
nach dem letzten Video,
was er hochgeladen hat.
Ich kenne ja noch jemand.
Und habe gesagt,
wie sieht es aus? Wollen wir etwas aufnehmen?
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher,
was das da, glaube ich,
hat er hochgeladen. Genau.
Da habe ich genau drauf geantwortet,
hier wäre nice, wenn wir da etwas aufnehmen.
Und ich kann euch schon sagen, was wir für ein Thema machen.
Und zwar, ich mache mal die Musik ein bisschen leiser.
Ich kann euch schon sagen,
was wir für ein Thema machen. Und zwar,
es gibt so viele Videos,
so, how to bekommen große,
erfolgreiche YouTuber. Aber niemand
macht ein Video.
Ich war mal erfolgreicher YouTuber
und mache keinen YouTube mehr.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine? So, es gibt total viele Videos,
how to become YouTuber, aber nicht
wie werde ich von YouTube wieder zu normal.
Und der M-Core war damals ja auch dick im Business.
Ich mache auch schon jahrelang kaum noch aktiv richtig was.
Könnten wir sich mal drüber auslassen.
Exzellent, exzellent.
How to be normie. Na gut, wir nicht.
Also ich schonmal, ich schonmal nicht.
Ich muss mal kurz hier
bringen, die VM neu starten.
Ich glaube, da ist ein bisschen was
im Argen gerade.
Die mag ich irgendwie nicht
so richtig. Das sieht
mittlerweile viel cooler aus. Ich habe vorhin was
nice gebastelt.
Äh, warte mal, wo habe ich den
Preischamp? Pull.
Oh, what the fuck.
Alter, ich kann
immer tippen.
So.
Reset.
In your face. Origin.
Master. Bam.
So, letztes Comet. Timer.
Alles klar, passt. So, ich reboote mal schnell.
Also, nicht den
Stream.
Master.
Ja, mittlerweile.
Ey.
Das wird sich irgendwie so viel
unsinnige Sachen aus.
Ja, was?
Was ist damit?
Ach, hat jemand gefragt,
wo es die Seite gibt, oder was?
Genau, die gibt es da.
Excellent.
Das coole ist,
ich habe auf meinem zweiten PC ein YouTube Video
Vorschau Ding.
Und da
sehe ich genau, dass es irgendwelche random
Schwachsinnensvideos sind, die gepostet werden, da muss ich gerade draufklicken.
He doesn't
know he lacks critical information.
Ah, ah, ah.
Record, haben wir doch? Gibt es doch?
Es gibt doch Ah, ah, ah
Record für Preischamp.
Äh, Kampf Kevin.
Kannst du beim
Preischamp vielleicht noch
Filter entzogen das
auch auf Lager?
Ich weiß nicht, ob der
Crawler das kann.
Was soll das denn heißen?
Auf Lager, ausschließlich Versand.
Was soll das jetzt genau bedeuten?
Du meinst Sachen, die
auch wirklich innerhalb der nächsten
ein, zwei Tage verschickt werden können, oder was?
Es war nur der Name frei zwei
acht Monate. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive IQ increase für den Chat,
wieder.
Die findet er aber doch auch so.
Die findet er doch auch so.
Hier, RTX war
vorhin am Start, habe ich genau gesehen,
während ich entwickelt habe. Guck hier,
bei Alternate ist er auch am Start.
Die findet er schon. Nee, aber ich glaube,
da habe ich keinen. Hier, passt doch.
Auf Lager, ausschließlich Versand.
Ja gut, wenn die, wenn die
30, wenn
wenn die
Das kann sein, dass das
noch nicht aktualisiert ist.
Nee.
Ach hier, guck mal.
Das kann sein, dass er die Produktseite nicht drin hat.
Warum ist das denn so teuer?
Ist das so gedacht?
Ja, also, die
müssen, die müssen da finden, wenn die Produktseite drin ist.
Das ist halt so ein
Ding, wenn die Produktseite, ich kann mal
gucken, ob die Produktseite drin ist. Kann man nachschauen.
Wartet mal. Schauen wir mal.
Hier.
Terminal aufmachen. Ich habe jetzt
Rebooted. So, gehen wir mal.
Wo habe ich das? Repos.
Street.
So.
Source.
Shops. Oh nee, wo haben sie das?
Stores. Wo haben sie das versteckt?
Model und dann
Alternate.
60,
90.
60, 90.
Ach, die steht gerade, die steht hier noch gar nicht drin.
Das ist ganz neu.
Haben sie noch gar nicht drin.
Aber 60, 80. Nee, warte.
Wie?
Ach,
es ist 6.800.
Doch, ist drin.
So, gucken wir mal, ob
eins von denen das ist, was du gezeigt
hast.
Ja, die links stimmen einfach nicht mehr.
Keck, Keck, Hyperweight.
Die links stimmen nicht.
So.
Welchen Link hast du gerade geschickt?
Den da.
Ja.
Siehst du? Das steht da einfach
nicht drin.
Tja, kein Wunder, dass es das nicht
krault.
Wenn es da nicht drin steht.
Wir pullen mal
hier aktuell. Der macht natürlich
mehr. Das ist auch schon wieder so eine Sache, warum man diese
Main-Master-Geschichte
auf den Keks geht.
Man kann einfach keinen History-Eintrag
mehr verwenden. Man muss dann
umwursten das Ganze.
Das nervt.
Und der hat Alternate, hat er nichts
gemacht. Also das ist immer noch nicht drinne.
Ich meine, wir können das
auch von Hand dazuschreiben, aber
ehrlich gesagt
ja scheiß drauf, wir schreiben das von Hand
dazu.
Ich weiß nicht.
Mal gucken, ob das russische Botnetz wieder am Start
ist heute. Nicht Pokchamp,
nicht Pokchamp.
Preischamp.
Mal gucken, ob das russische
Botnetz heute wieder zuguckt.
Nee, pingen kann ich ja nicht. Da lieg ich ja
wieder IPs.
Wir tragen das mal ein und gucken, ob es dann
funktioniert. Also
Source
Store
Model
Jetzt Alternate
und jetzt
6900 XT
Ich hab da noch nie was von Hand
eingetragen. Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Also
nehmen wir mal so ein Ding
Copypasten das
So und das ist jetzt Brand
Asus
AMD Reference. Ehrlich gesagt
kein Plastenschimmer, da steht überall
AMD
Ich schreib da einfach AMD Reference, ist doch egal.
So und jetzt ist Produktseite
Produktseite, die du
geschickt hast. Moment, wo ist die
Produktseite, die du geschickt hast? Ist das blöd?
Ich steh irgendwo weg.
Check, check, wait.
Wo hab ich die hin? Ach nee, da.
Hier. Blablabla
Product
Ok, wie
baustelle
Einfach so?
Ah ja, nice. Ok.
Massive Wim trick
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon kennt. Wenn
ihr in Anführungszeichen seid
Dann drückt ihr einfach C, I
und Anführungsstriche
und schon löscht alles. Bam. So, mal gucken
ob der das jetzt richtig crawlt.
Das ist nicht AMD. Ich nehm
dieses Model eh für nix, also ist es auch wurscht.
Start
So, der sollte das jetzt checken. Der sollte
jetzt, der Preischamp sollte
jetzt gleich
wenn er gestartet ist, das dauert ne Minute
oder so, sollte der jetzt anzeigen
AMD ist am Start.
Wann kann man wieder erwarten, dass der Staff
zu normalen Preisen am Start ist?
Irgendwann im Sommer?
So Leute, ich zeig euch jetzt mal den neuen
Preischamp. Ich hab ein bisschen was geupdatet
und wir machen heute ein bisschen Fine Tuning
dass ich mal wieder was neues pushen kann.
Weil wir wissen ja, die Leute stehen drauf, wenn es
neue Änderungen gibt, die sie sich angucken können.
Den machen wir mal zu.
Depots, Preischamp
.net
und
achso
Wir müssen vorher noch was anderes machen.
Weil
ich hab ja das Problem
Ich hab ja das Problem, dass
ach Moment, ich muss
Alter
JavaScript, lass dich doch einfach
Das ist hartnäckig
Ich wollte es eigentlich einfach nur abbrechen
ja
So
Wir müssen erstmal
ein Install machen, weil ich
hab ne
Craft Chart Library vorhin
installiert. Die ist ja hier sicherlich noch gar nicht drauf
Okay
So jetzt aber
Und wir müssen vorhin nämlich noch was anderes machen
Weil guckt mal, wir müssen das
verdockerisieren
Weil
wenn ich das hier starte
dann braucht das
Start
dann braucht das meine
komplette CPU-Leistung von der Kiste
Deswegen müssen wir das
verdockerisieren
und dann docker starten mit
CPU-Limit, viel einfacher
Ja richtig
Monarch-S
Das sollte aber relativ einfach sein, weil
der Typ hat ein Docker-File am Start
Das heißt theoretisch
können wir einfach sagen docker-build.
und dann funktioniert's
Mal gucken
ob das so ist, wie ich mir das denke
Und dann können wir starten im Docker
mit verschiedenen
Parameter für
CPU-Beschränkungen
Verdockerisieren sollte im Tuden stehen
Mittlerweile wird alles verdockerisiert
Ich warte noch drauf bis die Leute mal
LS-SSService verwenden
Oder
Top-SSS, wobei das gibt's schon
Bring soll ich euch nochmal was richtig
nicees zeigen
Grafana
Passt mal auf
Nodex-Porter
Extern
Ich hab mein
Beta-Preis-Champ
im
Grafana-Monitoring jetzt drin
Bäm
Und jetzt seh ich auch gleich, was hier abgeht mit
Traffic
Allerdings wie gesagt, der Server wird eh nicht lang aktiv
noch bleiben, sobald das irgendwie funktioniert
Zieh ich das um auf Preis-Champ.org
Und das kommt hinter Cloudflare
Ist das nicht Pog?
Oh
Leute, was ist das?
Das ist Statistik von meinem Server
bei Hetzner
50% CPU-Last
16 CPU-Cores, 2,4 Tage ab
32G RAM
RAM-Verbrauch ist nicht so hoch
Ist aber ganz gut
ausgelastet, die Kiste
Was ist
hinter Preis-Champ.org?
Da ist Kappe
1,2,3
Soll ich online? Ja, das dauert
Das dauert, bis der das erkennt
Das dauert, der muss ja erstmal alles
durchcrawlen und dann irgendwann mal
da ankommen, das dauert
Sobald ich ihn jetzt neu gestartet hab
Sonsten gehts schneller
Was kostet ich die Kiste? 50€ im Monat
Die fette
Aber ich werd das auch anders machen
Ich hab ja jetzt zum Test mal so eine 16-Core-Kiste
Ich werd das anders machen
Ich mach einen 8-Kerner zum Crawlen
und einen Dual- oder
Triple-Core fürs Frontend
Das Frontend kommt mit einem Core
aus, wenn man ehrlich ist
Du musst das horizontal skalierbar machen
Das geht sogar
Der Patrick bringt
mich auf eine Idee
Man kann das sogar relativ easy
mit Entspannungsmusik machen
Das ist zu entspannt
Relaxing-Nintendo-Musik
Das ist cool
Das war schon fast ein bisschen zu
Relaxing
Der Patrick hat mich auf eine echt geile Idee
gebracht
Jawoll
Und zwar
Es war natürlich nur
Gebat, aber
hat mich wirklich auf eine gute Idee gebracht
Das ist
Das hab ich nicht selbst gemacht
Das ist das fertige
Notexporter-Dashboard
Warte mal, wo war das denn?
Man kann das sogar relativ
einfach skalieren
Ich könnte einfach
3 Server nehmen
mit dem Crawler drauf
Und auf dem ersten Server mach ich
Shops 1-5, dann mach ich Shops
auf dem zweiten Server 5-10
und auf dem dritten Server 10-15
Also Shops, Stores
Also die Läden, wo man kaufen kann
Das wird funktionieren
Und das Frontend
Das kann man nicht gescheit skalieren
Dazu müsste ich das von
SQLite auf Postgres oder irgendwas umbauen
Dann könnte man das auch
richtig
Serverless
High
Serverless High Availability
Horizontal Scaling
Enable
Ok, Dogger-Container ist gebaut
Exquisite
Ich muss mal ein Beispiel
bei denen suchen
Gering Star, der hatte doch so
ein Docker-Beispiel
Nur, dass wir das nicht wollen von dem
Das wollen wir nicht von dem, wir wollen mal
ein eigenes Docker-Image
Passt
Und jetzt müssen wir nämlich noch angeben, dass wir CPU limitieren wollen
Das ist, wenn der Kram im Dogger-Container läuft
viel einfacher, weil
wenn man Lokal-CPU limitieren will
Einfach CPUs 2 und gut ist
Wenn man nämlich Lokal-CPUs limitieren will, geht das
Aber spätestens, wenn man einen Prozess
limitiert, der weitere Prozesse startet
geht's nicht
Kann man später auch Manuellprodukte
Nein, kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht
Kannst da nichts einstellen
Du weißt ja gar nicht
wie die ganzen Urls von den Shops
und sowas sind, also du weißt das vielleicht schon
aber der Crawler
weißt das ja nicht
Der kann ja nix crawlen, explizit für dich
Das wäre ja riesen
Aufwand, wenn jeder sein eigenes
Zeug da rein macht
Tja, Docker funktioniert das, aber
wenn man ein bisschen CPU-Set macht, funktioniert's nicht
Also, wie gesagt
Im Dogger-Container ist es am einfachsten
CPU zu beschreiten. Guck mal, ob das funktioniert
Der sollte sich jetzt ein bisschen im Rahmen halten
Oh, ich muss noch vorher was ändern
Ich muss die Adresse, wo er
einliefert, ändern
Zwar, was hab ich denn lokal für eine IP
hier auf meiner Kiste
2.31
So, das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren
Start
Burger King Coupons
Irgendwann, irgendwann
mach ich sowas
Irgendwann mach ich sowas
Ich könnte das ohne Scheiß, ich könnte das
aus Spaß, ich mach das aus Spaß rein
Burger King Coupons
Wo gibt's die?
Die mach ich rein, das ist einfach
Das ist witzig, wenn Burger King
Coupons gibt
Das ist lustig, wenn's dann einfach neben
Hardware noch Burger King Coupons gibt
Sag mal, welche Seite kann ich erkennen
ob's die gibt?
Eigentlich sollte der jetzt
beschränkt sein auf 2 CPUs
Warum ist der nicht auf 2 CPUs beschränkt?
Also normalerweise
sollte er das sein
Ach, weil ich NPM Start gemacht hab
Alter
Richtig dumm
Pains Champ
So, und jetzt zeig ich euch die neue
Preis Champ Version
Ah, so ist gut, guck mal hier
So ist das viel besser
My Deals einfach via
Feed Reader, das ist ne gute Idee
Da muss ich nen Custom-Crawler basteln
aber das ist ne gute Idee
Und die haben dann
RSS-Feed oder was?
So?
Ne
Wo gibt's denn hier
nen RSS-Feed von denen?
Ami
Hier, RSS-Hot
Exzellent
Da können wir nämlich mal gucken
Was gibt's? Da gibt's Burger King
Gibt's den auch gar nicht
Chat
Gibt keinen Burger King
Anzeige ist raus
und
King
Aber die Idee ist gut
Die Idee ist gut
Die Idee ist auf jeden Fall gut
Ok, jetzt passt's
Ok, so jetzt starte ich den lokalen Preis Champ
Und jetzt zeig ich euch mal was Neues
Jetzt richtig
Massive Nice gemacht
Aber mir gefällt's optisch schon nicht so 100%
Das können wir jetzt im Stream machen
Dass es dann hübsch aussieht bevor ich das pushe
Out aufmachen
Chrome aufmachen
Jetzt zeig ich euch den lokalen Preis Champ
Warum hab ich den scheißen Lokal noch laufen?
Keck weh
Wann hab ich das gestartet?
Warte mal
Wo hab ich denn das überhaupt gestartet?
Läuft da noch irgendein Docker-Container oder so?
Ach der Crap ist noch am Start, Alter
Stopp
Haben die sich neu gestartet?
Wo hab ich denn den Kram Docker-Composed?
Hier?
Meine exzellente Benamung
Weißt du sofort Bescheid
Das da? Nee
Ich mein
Das ist es
Down
Was?
Das ist es
Die
Keck, warte
Wo hab ich denn das?
Ok dann lösche ich den Kram von Hand
Docker stopp
das da, das da, das da, docker, images, was hab ich denn, alter was ist da alles dabei,
äh, lull, na gut, kann ich den auch nochmal löschen, so, jetzt muss ich das Surf nochmal
neu machen, so, und jetzt zeige ich euch den neuen Preis-Champ, alter, minus v ist version,
ne, minus v ist doch eigentlich löschen, ach, es ist minus, es ist down minus v, ne,
das kommt auch noch auf die, das kommt auch noch auf die, ok, das ist echt hängen geblieben,
das ist echt hängen geblieben, das, das minus v, was anderes ist wie das, ne, es ist minus
v, was war minus v an der falschen Stelle, keck wait, ok, jetzt zeige ich euch den neuen
Preis-Champ, bam, es ist noch kein großer Unterschied, erstens, das allerwichtigste,
pass mal auf, ich hab, ich hab nen, nen Alarmsymbol gefunden, was mich nicht mehr triggert, guck
mal, das ist jetzt properly aligned alles, ja, also da, da zuckelt kein Alken mehr rum,
allerwichtigste, ohne hätt ich nicht weiter gemacht, so, und jetzt, guck mal, wenn du
jetzt hier drauf gehst, an der Preis-Champ eigentlich jetzt mal die, die rtx gefunden,
ne, aber guck mal, die andere rtx ist jetzt auch weg, lull, so, pass mal auf, wenns jetzt
geht, all die musik, die musik ist ja monkaS, so, pass mal auf, wenn man jetzt hier drauf
drückt, 30.90, bam, das gefällt mir aber optisch noch nicht so ganz, also, man kriegt
angezeigt, welche Shops den Kram haben, man kann hier den Shop öffnen, sortiert nach
Preis, und man sieht, wann der das gefunden hat, und die Zeit tickt runter, also sprich,
hier weiß man, das ist noch ziemlich, ziemlich aktuell refreshed, guck, der geht, ich find's
auch cool, wie redet das wieder hoch animiert, und so, da ist der Chat im Weg, achso, guck
mal, seht ihr mal, wie hyper responsive das ganze ist, massive responsive, huge responsive,
exellent, so, guckt, und hier sieht man auch, wann er immer zuletzt gecrawlt hat, und das
tickt dann runter, ich mein, das sind halt 15 Minuten, das tickt ein bisschen langsam
runter, also sprich, nach 15 Minuten time outed, das ist ja eh, ich hab das so eingestellt,
wenn der was findet, und wenn er es innerhalb von 15 Minuten nicht nochmal gefunden hat,
dann geht's weg, so, und wenn man dann hier oben drauf drückt, kann man sich die ganzen
Angebote angucken, guck da, lagern, nur noch eine, Leute, bald gibt's nichts mehr, mehr
Storngs für Media, äh, für Mindfab, wie komm ich auf Media Markt, Mindfabry, auch
noch hier am Start, Alter, die Preise, was ist denn mit denen los, das ist einfach 1000
Euro teurer als angekündigt, so, aber das ist schon sehr nice, oder, übrigens, die
Storngs stimmen nicht, by the way, ne, also das ist einfach nur ein fixer Graph, der sich
nicht ändert, das ist noch null dynamisch, aber ich hab gedacht, ich bau das schon mal
hin, weil das cool aussieht, lass einfach starten, fällt eh keinem auf bei den Preisen
aktuell, merkt doch eh keiner, by the way, warum braucht der denn so lange, bis er das
Ding geladen hat, ah, guck mal, ich hab da noch ein Bug drin, guck mal, das Verbug,
das braucht so lang, weil der immer erst mal eine Sekunde braucht, guck mal, das riecht
stumm, da muss ich gleich mal fixen, äh, Timer, äh, Timer, Timer, hier Timer da,
jetzt machen wir anders, jetzt machen wir anders, dann ist es nämlich auch instant da,
Update, Alter, ich kann heute nicht mehr tippen, das ist zu viel, Update, und dann, bevor
wir das gestartet haben, noch mal ein Update, und jetzt ist es auch instant am Start, passt
auf, zack, ohne dass das irgendwie erst laden muss, instant, instant Timer, instant Timer
am Start, äh, by the way, soll ich den Chat irgendwo anders hinschieben, dass man das
da besser sieht, ich könnte den Chat, wo schieben wir den Chat hin, unten links, ich weiß nicht,
ich glaub unten links ist nicht so spannend gerade, unten links, da fehlt ein bisschen
was von meinem Terminal Output oder so, aber das juckt ja nicht, guck mal mal, ja, also
sprich, ihr seht, das tickt auch runter, und sobald sich das Refreshed, das können wir
mal abwarten, aktuell gibt es bloß 3 Sachen, gibt bloß 3 Läden mit 30,90, ok, was sagt
der Preischamp hier dazu, ah, der hat ja noch gar keine History, lull, ja, nur 3 Läden
mit 30,90 gerade, aber sobald es aktuell ist, das ist ja übrigens auch live im Vergleich
zu gestern, ne, also, wenn jetzt hier ein neuer Laden dazukommt, wir können ja mal kurz,
wir können ja mal kurz zugucken, ob der irgendwie eine 30,90 hier findet, ah, der ist gerade
bei 60,80 am Crawlen, ok, 30,80, wenn das eine 30,90 bei einem anderen Laden findet,
dann ploppt das jetzt hier dynamisch auf, also sprich, man muss wirklich nichts mehr
zu machen und aktualisieren, was haltet ihr denn davon, wie viel Schweizer Shops haben
die denn da drinnen, ich lasse es einfach mal laufen, wir gucken mal, wie viel Schweizer
Shops, ob sich das überhaupt lohnt, da einen Schalter zu machen für Schweiz und Österreich,
aber die meisten deutschen Shops liefern doch auch nach Österreich und Schweiz, oder,
oder nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin, Austria, jetzt die Musik bisschen
lauter, oh ne, passt, Austria, Switz, wie, Keg-Wade, die Schweiz gibt es da gar nicht,
Zauerei, Repos, Street-Virgent, gucken wir mal, Stores, Store, kannst du grundsätzlich
alle EU-Shops crawlen, ne, na gut, UK ist ja kein EU mehr, aber es gibt genug EU-Shops,
die halt wahrscheinlich gar nicht nach Deutschland liefern, im Zweifelsfall, zumindest UK ist
vorbei, UK liefert nicht mal nach, nach DE, also Overclockers hab ich rausgeschmissen,
was ist denn, was ist denn John Lewis, hört sich an wie irgendein Wrestler oder so, aber
es ist anscheinend, so, Crab, mal nach Punkt AT, mal gucken, gibt es keinen, und gibt es
einen CH-Shop, lull, ok, es gibt keine Schweizer Shops und keine AT-Shops, also im Prinzip
lohnt sich das nicht, Digitech, gibt es nicht, nach was, Brack, alter, ne, gibt es nicht,
kein Brack, kein Brack, Digga, alter, Digga, Digitech, ne, gibt es nicht, guck mal, er
hat live geupdatet hier, wir haben es zwar nicht gesehen, guck, jetzt hat er hier auch
gerade Alternate geupdatet, die Animation ist ein bisschen schnell, oder, das sieht so
aus, als backt es rum, ich sollte die Animation ein bisschen langsamer machen, für dieses
einfaden, machen wir das eine Sekunde lang, dann sieht es eher so aus, als wollte ich,
dass es updatet, ah, den Fix habe ich eh noch gar nicht drinnen, Moment, Moment, Minus
eins, das habe ich doch gestern, gestern habe ich das schon mal, gestern habe ich das schon
mal gefixt, Moment, Price, also, das ist noch der von gestern, Cacquait, das ist noch
das von gestern, wartet mal, ja, geil, null, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz reverten, das
hat, irgendwie, Wistel Studio hat das zwischengecashed, warum auch immer, Kackding, ich mache einfach
mal alles zu, alles weg, was will das immer von mir, piss dich, alte, geh fort, so, jetzt
schauen wir mal, was der hier drin hat, Serious Box, äh, ach ne, das ist doch richtig, passt
doch alles, alles gut, alles gut, passt, ist doch richtig, so, also Asus Minus eins muss
gefixt werden, hier, Asus Minus eins muss gefixt werden, also gucken wir mal, das heißt,
wenn der Preis, hier, das da müssen wir machen, also wenn der Preis, äh ja, irgendwie reloaded
kann nicht, but why, so, also, wenn, wenn der Preis, kleiner null ist, dann zeigen wir
an, dann zeigen wir an, äh, kein Preis verfügbar, ja, das hatten wir gestern auch so, haben
wir im Alter einen Api, um den Preis abzurufen, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, die sind da auch glaube
ich nicht so scharf drauf gecrawlt zu werden, aber die aktuelle Liefersituation, ähm,
bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig, kann man den Chat nach oben, oben rechts machen,
irgendwie ist der Chat überall im Weg heute, Chat, zu dick, Chat ist heute zu pepo fett,
die können es oben links hin machen, ich habe eine andere Idee, wir machen einfach
so, wir machen so, ach Moment, das, das, ihh, null, boah, das sieht ja kacke aus,
der Chat ist jetzt kleiner als sonst, ne, der Chat, der Chat war doch vorher eher immer,
Chat, ich glaube ich habe es kaputt gemacht, warte mal, wie resetet man das jetzt nochmal,
transform, reset, Chat, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie groß ich euch immer hatte, so, rückgängig
machen kann man hier nicht, soll der größer oder wart ihr noch größer, so, wo mache
ich euch denn jetzt mal hin, wartet mal, wartet mal, ich habe eine Idee, da konnte man noch
die Zeilen einstellen oder, ne, man kann die Zeilen nicht einstellen, na geil, ok Chat,
so mache ich euch hin, wartet mal, ich habe noch eine andere Idee, so Chat, also ich mache
jetzt mal unten rechts nochmal hin und jetzt machen wir aber die Höhe von 300 mal runter
auf 150, das sollte nur die Hälfte hoch sein und dementsprechend solltet ihr dann eigentlich
nirgendwo drüber sein, ok Chat, mal was testen, irgendwas spammen, gucken wie viele Zeilen
der jetzt da drin anzeigen kann, ja jetzt seid ihr nirgendwo drüber, komm mal Chat,
jetzt seid ihr nirgendwo drüber, Golden Kappa Test, perfekt, so lassen wir das, alles klar,
gut, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, wir wollten das mit keinem Preis verfügbar fixen, also
Leute wisst ihr was mir noch nicht so, was mir noch nicht wirklich gut gefällt, ist
dieser Timer, der sieht da so fehler am Platz aus irgendwie, ne, habt ihr eine bessere Idee
wo ich den hin machen kann, dürft nicht vergessen hier oben, das kann ganz schön lang werden,
zum Beispiel wenn da Notebooks billiger drin steht, dann geht der Überschrift bis hier,
weiter woher findet ihr das besser, wenn das direkt hier oben verlinkt ist oder mit diesem
öffnen Button, ich find gerade im Detail View ist das mit diesem öffnen Button eigentlich
ganz nice, ich mein wir könnten den, wir könnten das Bild vorne weg machen und dafür
den Timer hin machen, aber das Bild hat was, weil wir machen die Bilder ja je nachdem wie
teuer das ist, so wie es ist, ich weiß nicht, das sieht irgendwie nicht sonderlich gut
durchdacht aus oder gerade wenn hier kein Preis steht, wobei wir können einfach nur
kein Preis hinschreiben, du könnt den Timer rechts vorm Preis machen, ja hab ich doch,
das ist wann er das gesehen hat, ja, einfach im durchsichtlichen Kreis wo der
Border kleiner wird, ein durchsichtlicher Kreis wo der Border kleiner wird, also quasi
jetzt, ich mein man könnte auch ne Progress Bar da unten hin machen, das ist zu big brain
für mich, man könnte das sogar im Hintergrund irgendwie machen, Progress um das
ganze Feld, oh das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, Serious Maxi meinst du das durchsichtliche
Preis, wir könnten auch ne Progress, oh exellent, ach so, also du meinst ohne Zahl drinne oder
was, wir könnten auch ne Progress Bar machen, gucken wir mal wie das aussieht, ich vermute
mal das können wir einfach austauschen, nee können wir nicht, ok Rotate gibt es schon
mal nicht dafür, alter was stört ihn jetzt, was stört ihn jetzt da dran, ach so das muss
er wahrscheinlich größer machen, jetzt muss man das hier wahrscheinlich raus machen,
ah hier, wow was jetzt, was hab ich jetzt kaputt gemacht, höchst besser sieht das
ja nicht aus, so, wir könnten das unten an der Box machen, das ist glaub ich gar keine
so schlechte Idee, so die Zahl muss halt weg, wobei das sieht aus wie Verfügbarkeit, das
verwirrt die Leute, genau, genau, ohne Zahl sieht das so aus als ist das irgendwie Verfügbarkeit
oder so, hm, kein Preis ist natürlich das beste, der niedrigste.
Ja gut aber die Zahl die geht da ja nicht hin, die Zahl die sieht halt mega bescheuert
aus, nee das sieht total beknackt aus wenn ich da eine Zahl hin mache, man müsste höchstens
irgendwie nebeneinander machen oder so, geht gar nicht, mach doch die Zahl trotzdem dahin,
da wo vorher der Kreis war, das funktioniert nicht richtig, weil das ist alles in einer
Komponente drin, die Zahl und das the progress das krieg ich da nicht hin, das ist guck mal
das ist super responsive, pass mal auf, huge responsive, siehste das wie massive responsive
das ist, exquisite responsive, so, ja das sieht kacke aus, machs mal wieder rückgängig,
warum checkt der das net, das ist wieder rund, der soll das jetzt gefälligst rund anzeigen,
so jetzt mach ich das ja auch mal wieder rückgängig, ach nee, ok leute ich glaube ich lasse das
jetzt einfach mal so mir fällt nichts besseres gerade ein, mir fällt gerade echt nichts
besseres ein dazu, so also bevor ich das pushe, was meint ihr, was soll ich denn mit dem unten
war besser, ja aber unten sagt das absolut gar nichts, also unten, genau, wenn das unten
ist denkt man das ist irgendwie verfügbarkeit, ja wie könnte man das denn machen, dass man
es versteht, ich mein, ich hab ne Idee, leute ich hab ne Idee, ich hab ne Idee, wir machen
das anders, guck mal wartet mal, wir schreiben da gar keine zahl rein, wir schreiben da gar
keine zahl rein, wir schreiben da rein, wir machen dann icon rein, wie wärs mal mit updaten,
was ist denn los hier, normalerweise macht das updaten das automatisch, na das sieht
auch nicht gut aus oder, braucht man das überhaupt, ja das ist schon nicht schlecht zu wissen weil
man das gefunden hat zuletzt, das sieht dumm aus, na vielleicht, ne ok das sieht dumm aus,
ich mein wir könntens hier unten drunter machen in klein oder, warum machen wirs nicht
unter das keck w in klein, ja zeitstempel hatte ich vorher, das sah auch nicht gut aus,
wir machen das mal unter das keck w in klein, ok wir machen die zahl weg, dann machen wir
den kram kleiner und das in der mitte fetter, so, das zeigt was er zuletzt refreshed hat,
so und jetzt, und jetzt, richtig agile, ja, und jetzt zeigen wir das unter dem keck w
an, so wo ist der hier, da, kann man das jetzt einfach hier unten drunter machen, äh, äh,
wartet mal, ne das sieht kacke aus, ich war mal die höhe irgendwie auf 60 oder so, oh,
das war die, ist das irgendein flex oder was ist da, was passiert nur jetzt wenn ich dem
einfach sag, margin top 15 oder so, gehts dann runter, ne, wie krieg ich denn das jetzt
runter, dann break dazwischen, float wirds auch nicht tun wahrscheinlich, äh, also float
wirds auf jeden fall nicht bringen, so, ich mein wir können das eingebaute zeug verwenden,
sollte das einsch machen, äh, wov wird der immer schlimmer, fast, fast, fast, wir nähern
uns, wir nähern uns leute, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns der sache, guck mal, guck
mal, fast, fast, äh, äh, äh, excellent, ein bisschen höher müßt man es glaub ich
noch machen, jetzt ist zu hoch, 70, auch zu hoch, 60, warum schneidet der das denn da
unten ab, was ist das für, was ist das für ein kacknooper, 18, warum schneidet der das
ab, will er mich rollen, anzeige ist raus, äh, ok, so, äh, den preis denn der ist nicht
richtig, nicht richtig ausgerichtet, wahrscheinlich kann ich den ganzen kram jetzt hier wegmachen,
äh, so, excellent, excellent, das sieht doch jetzt aber schon mal ganz gut aus oder, man
kann besser also ein kringel da irgendwo nehmen, pacman frister's zeichen, das sieht aber immer
noch wie ne menge aus, das gefällt mir nicht, ich war, ach, keine ahnung, ich mein wir können
doch einfach nen timestamp hin machen, und nen progress bar war am besten, ja dann machen
wir einfach, dann schreiben wir wirklich einfach die zeit hin, kann man ja machen, das ist
kein ding, dann machen wir das weg, so, dann kann ich nämlich auch diesen ganzen müll
da unten weg machen, äh, das hab ich jetzt verkackt, warum ist denn das jetzt untereinander,
das ist doch normalerweise nie untereinander, span sein, ahja, ok, ok, passt, ok, ok, ok,
alles, was in zeit 38, oh, ich mein wir können da einfach nen timestamp drunter machen, das
geht, aber letztendlich mal im ernst, interessiert es überhaupt irgendjemand, wann er zuletzt
abgefragt hat, ich mein es verschwindet halt einfach nach 15 Minuten, eigentlich ist die
doch wurscht oder? Das reicht doch komplett was da drin steht. Ich kann die Zeit mal neben
dem preis probieren vielleicht vielleicht etwas andere variante
das ist das ist ist auch nicht wirklich besser oder? Oder? Ja gut dann lassen wir es erst
mal so serious marks was meinst du als exzellent frontend expert nicht mehr das
ist das bei dir sieht das anders aus bei mir im bei bei mir im browser ist es 12
stunden stimmt wir könnten das wir könnten das nach sekunden wir könnten
das vorweg wir können hinschreiben vor ich habe die nachricht jetzt gar nicht
gesehen was habe ich wieder zu was habe ich was zum lachen verpasst
man könnte wirklich hinter guck mal wenn er wenn er anstatt die zeit stehen würde
wenn man da einfach hinschreibt wir gucken wir vor vor 13 minuten ist das das
wäre doch besser oder das das wäre doch das wäre doch eins besser
jepp
das ist gut dann machen wir das da gibt es da gibt es doch bestimmt schon
irgendwas fertig ist um den kram umzurechnen ich meine ich könnte meinen
timer mein timer progress zu umbauen dass der das dass der das ausrechnet
weil du brauchst ja einen timer sonst aktualisiert er das nicht na also ich
mein das ist gar nicht mal so einfach kann das
also ich meine in sekunden umrechnen ist kein problem
ok ich ich ich ich ich werde mal mein ich werde mal meinen timer umwursten zu
was was das anzeigen kann hier
ich werde mal meinen timer umwursten zu was was das anzeigen kann
was ist denn jetzt das problem was keck wait was
was das hatte ich doch eben drinnen es all oder die bin die klärt
moment importierst du es mehrfach
warum das denn wo kommt das auf einmal her
ne hab ich da gemacht war das auto im das ja das war auto import auto import
scheint nicht so clever zu sein ok so jetzt jetzt wurscht jetzt wusste ich
nehme ich dieses dieses um diesen timer um zu einfach nur texte hinten dran
steht so time out also der ganze mist kommt weg
alle was mit der musik los eigentlich gerade im hintergrund das ist ja absolut
monach es muss ich so irgendwie ich muss ich muss man hätte sein ein kloten ich
höre mich auf der linken seite nicht mehr
so es passt für die richtige agile arbeitsgruppe hier im chat wieder ok
jetzt kommt dieses progress ding weg und wir schreiben da einfach nur noch genau
so also diese die minuten habe ich schon die minuten habe ich die sekunden habe
ich auch
das ist gar nicht so einfach das umzuwandeln
doch gibt es doch bestimmt schon irgendwas fertig ist für
j.s. convert time to time ago oder so
weil die sekunden habe ich ja also mit sekunden ist es einfach mit sekunden
ist es einfach schreibe ich aber vor sekunden so fertig
ach so start gleich also in sekunden ist das einfach
ups aber das müsste man jetzt umrechnen gibt es eigentlich ein format für oder
so hat das ja ja was gibt auch bestimmt irgendwie so ein so ein so ein format
time format string gedöns oder ich meine das ist auf jeden fall schon mal schon
mal besser ok j.s. format string time
wie das muss doch so was haben das hat doch alles
ich mache da jetzt nicht moment j.s. rein nur für sie für sowas
wie das muss doch format
das muss doch sowas haben to local time string das das habe ich glaube ich auch
schon mal verwendet das options genau options time so ein aus format matcher
alter warum ist das so ultra kompliziert in java script wieder was ist denn hier los
ok ok das ist java script kompliziert aber es scheint zu funktionieren also
also also ok das heißt monka es also also also wie jetzt keck keck wait also
moment mal also time ist die musik wills auch gerade wissen time so jetzt haben wir
chat im weg schon so hier datetime
chat ich blende euch aus hier guckt mal jetzt könnt ihr zugucken
ich blende euch nicht aus also das ist detail und was muss man da jetzt machen
monka es options alter was zum
nicht spanien de de ok ok ok so und jetzt will ich will es ich will es eigentlich
gar nicht will überhaupt kein day ich will eigentlich nur minute und so
formatieren minute so kann man kann man kann man das aus
wenn ich zu lokal times kann man da sagen falls oder so was dass er das
weglässt
aber wenn man das nicht angibt dann ist es weg oder was
oh moment ich bin übelst verwirrt da fuck ich muss es ja vorher ich mein ich
muss es ja vorher voneinander abziehen auch noch ich will es ja gar nicht ich
will ja ich will ja new ich will ja datetime now minus date aber das geht
ja nicht ah wie ziehe ich in java script zwei zwei zeiten voneinander ab
wozu schreiben wir hier was hier das da guck mal preis preis tracker habe ich
erweitert an java script macht mich fertig ok man kann also man zwei dates
kann man nicht voneinander abziehen js subtract date da muss es doch
irgendwas geben autos abt ein bisschen was neueres please get time und das dann
voneinander ok ok also get time
moment das habe ich doch hier oben schon gemacht
get time ist millisekunden seit 1970 beta.preischepp.org
jetzt kann ich natürlich nicht mehr formatieren alter das ist mir zu dumm
ich meine ich habe ja so gekam hier schon programmiert so das ist das ist
für sekunden das sind die sekunden das kann ich eigentlich schon mal verwenden
kann ich jetzt aus den sekunden neu ins neues date machen geht das irgendwie
es geht bestimmt das geht bestimmt das probiere ich jetzt aus ok new date aus
den sekunden
aha das das sieht das sieht sogar schon mal ganz gut aus das sieht sogar schon
mal ganz brauchbar aus
eins
ach man kann er einfach man kann er ernsthaft to string machen das geht
moment wenn es so einfach ist
hey quake so einfach ist es nicht ok aber aber ich copy paste jetzt mal den
chat ich glaube passt jetzt mal den chat
chat easy ich glaube ich das jetzt einfach mal gucken ob ich jebaited
werde geht nicht easy aber man muss dann bestimmt
clear time is not a function siehste der chat jebaited mich
und add seconds geht wahrscheinlich auch nicht ich will eine sekundenanzahl
umwandeln in minute sekunde mit javascript build ins ich will da nicht
anfangen mit wenn größer als 60 dann eine minute dazu und sowas
da muss eigentlich was eingebautes für geben was hier das was da in den chat
gepostet hat ging schon mal
wie gesagt das js epoch to date wie geht das
kann man kann man nicht
what oh jetzt wird es wahnsinn alter der chat der chat will es wissen jetzt
passt auf ok
jetzt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert leute
beim easy also moment javascript logik moment das was ich gemacht habe war doch
gar nicht so verkehrt das war sich so gemacht was ich so gemacht hat war doch
gar nicht verkehrt warum geht warum ging das bei mir nicht das ist doch mehr oder
weniger fast das gleiche wartet mal
hätte ich das mal 1000 rechnen müssen
das ist milliseconds das ist nicht sekunden seit 1970 das in millisekunden
seit 1970 alter wo kommt da überhaupt die stunde her jetzt wo kommt da wo kommt
wo kommt da jetzt wo genau kommt da die stunde her
so und jetzt options adi zeitzone das wird da macht auch noch zeitzonen
geschiss ok bei minuten interessiert uns das mit zeitzeitzonen natürlich nicht
ok also wie der man nicht kann man jetzt sagen aber ok aber kann ich jetzt
einfach minutes was ist wenn ich das weglasse
der macht immer die fucking stunde dahin aber to time string bringt an sich
an nichts kann man da auch optionen übergeben kann man da options übergeben
kann man da options über geht
ne warum kann man ach so einfach nur options ja ja war script ich check die
logik nicht warum kann ich bei local time string was übergeben und bei
was
wo ist denn jetzt das problem
nehmen doch einfach eine fertig ich habe doch schon was was funktioniert aber ich
will nur wissen was wie weit ich da jetzt davon entfernt war das aber ist
noch die feind ach so ok ja ja gefahrt
und
ja quä kann man da options übergeben das
macht mich fertig
wobei das was was der was der chat verwendet ist eigentlich noch besser
das kann er jetzt sein und ich will einfach keine stunde anzeigen warum
haben wir nicht einfach mit dem time format ding ist das ist ist das zu zu
high level für für java script leute oder wie ok auch man kann auch nicht
einfach null schreiben dass das weglässt oder ne das geht nicht
meinst du wenn ich aber wenn ich da minutes angebe
so nicht verfunktionieren so ich nehme jetzt das was der chat gepostet hat
excellent und dann ist gut einfach so zack gut ist ich nehme einfach das was
der was der was der chat was der chat geschrieben hat chat chat kennt sich aus
wissen wir excellent chat immer excellent drauf der chat
excellent timer timer da brauche ich noch was anderes dafür irgendwie go oder so das
ist bestimmt ein string der da zurückkommt das go gleich
ja
moment warum ist der warum ist da 00 warum ist moment moment moment von da
muss ich bestimmt später anfangen 13 oder so ja 14 und dann irgendwie nur 4 5
aber das funktioniert doch auch nur ok wartet mal wenn die erste zahl null wird
ob das dann auch funktioniert ok ok nice nice ok alles klar excellent
mit minute oder ohne ich glaube die die einheit können wir uns sogar schenken
weil die meisten leute das checken wenn sie das so sehen glaubt das kann man so
lassen wie es jetzt ist wie lange haben wir jetzt an dem scheiß rumgemacht
sorry ich hab falls ich irgendwelche subs übersehen hab muss mich gerade über
ja fast krebt pp gar die zeiten zählen runter da stimmt was nicht sekunde
das falsch rum das falsch rum wartet mal aber das lässt sich glaube ich einfach
fixen
aha
so
das ist das gefällt mir das hat doch was oder finde ich auch das doch schick nur
dass es nicht richtig allein ist aber das ist in ordnung so lassen wir das
alles gut bevor ich habe kein bock mehr da weiter dran rum zu machen wir allein
ist noch mal kurz die die currency richtig
warum allein das nicht
warum allein sich das nicht jetzt was ist hier los ist das ist das vielleicht
das hat es refresh nicht gecheckt warum allein sich das jetzt nicht mehr eben
ging es auch noch ich krieg anfälle excellent frontend kann ich einfach
sagen
dann wenn sich das nicht allein dann mache ich einfach das das ding hoch und
gut ist das allein sich einfach gar nicht was hat kein bock mehr ist dem
vollkommen egal kann ich auch wegschmeißen was ist das ist margin
right margin bottom margin left aber so ist ok ich fasse es nicht wahr leute so
bleibt es jetzt schluss so so so bleibt es jetzt fertig so das update machen
noch auf eine sekunde hoch dann sieht es ein bisschen gewollter aus so sehr
schön soll ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher was mit dem graf mache
übrigens wisst ihr wisst ihr was ich mir überlegt habe ja das sieht viel
cooler aus oder wenn es die sekunde wenn es die sekunde braucht dann sieht es
dann habt ihr es gerade gesehen in sekunde sieht das viel gewollter aus die
animation so was ist welche umfrage ich habe es nicht gesehen exquisite umfrage
was was gibt es für eine umfrage
eine umfrage vorgeschlagen umfrage ja was für eine umfrage
ah könnte man ja hier habe ich habe ich
alter chat also eine umfrage vorschlagen könnte man in den grafen für den
preisverlauf noch einen balken für den uvp machen damit man preis besser
einschätzen kann ja das haben das haben wir uns letztes mal auch schon überlegt
ob man das machen kann aber das ding ist schon ganz schön ganz schön beladen
also sprich die uvp könnte man entweder wie könnte man das machen
also eigentlich mein ursprünglicher plan war das bild ändert sich je nach
abweichung zum uvp das das das fängt dann an wenn es wenn es richtig billig
ist wenn es richtig billig ist fängt es dann fängt es dann irgendwie so an
über so und hört dann irgendwie so auf oder so
und kein preis kein preis kriegt ein anderes emote moment wartet mal price
was klatter balken ins diagramm hier oben balken
aber aber solche balken rein machen das sieht doch so viel besser aus als mit
einem balken ach so uvp so ein ding das ist eine gute idee das gefällt mir das
ist nice das das das müssen wir mal gucken wie man das macht ich habe keine
ahnung wie das geht das ist chargers ich habe einfach
einen statisches statischen kraft drin aktuell
das geht das geht garantiert das geht
ja
was ich muss ein plugin verwenden dafür
ernsthaft
kann doch nicht sein das geht garantiert auch so ohne ohne plugin
also das ist data
wir machen einfach ein zweites data set rein was was einfach
was einfach nur so geht passt mal auf das kann man bestimmt machen data set
und jetzt einfach irgendwie eins was die ganzen zeit nur so geht ja easy border
eins by the way warum also was ist und was ist in der uvp 1500
zu schnell copy pasted kann er das nicht automatisch extenden muss ich da wirklich
für jeden punkt ein angeben ich will diesen diesen diesen huppel hier aber
weg haben falls das soll nicht gefilmt werden das soll gefilmt
aber wie kriege ich da die die knubbel weg aber bei spiel ist ein schon mal ganz
gut ja preis es ist nicht preis es ist uvp das ist eine richtig coole idee leute
aber der graf ist halt eh statisch wir haben die die infos habe ich noch gar
nicht ich habe die infos aber das gute ist ich kann das jederzeit füllen ich
habe nämlich die infos in der datenbank stehen elements radius point excellent
der chat kennst damit aus ups nein aber fast aber fast oder oder nee wohin wohin
damit
was ist das point radius null
ich hab von der library kein plastenschimmer
ups ich muss aber richtig schreiben können ne ne ne so auch nicht in die options ja
aber wo sind die options gibt es also gibt options so was
fast und ne dann gilt ja für alle für alle will ich das nicht für alle ist das doof ich
muss mal googeln ja ok moment halt points in kraft das ist ja nur für einen moment
ist das ja das ist global you can set point radius aha aha siehste so geht das
also so geht das ist einfach mal google google magic gemacht nice
so und wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen wir nehmen jetzt die gleiche linie wie oben im
header ich gebe dir header alter das ist auch das gefällt mir das schick oder heute jetzt
jetzt habe ich eine idee habe ich einen color picker habe ich einen color picker was ist
ein guter color picker für linux color picker color picker e color color 3 excellent ich
baue irgendwas was mit knorrm keyring ok was auch immer der alles damit installiert ok
e color picker so und wie pick ich jetzt color wie funst das geht das nicht der scheiß kronbst
ich hätte erwartet ich klicke da drauf und dann kann ich was was was color kram aber ich
glaube das geht nicht oder die da sind noch das problem ist dass das gnome zeug geht nicht
wenn wenn kein chrome gestartet ist glaube ich mal je color alles wieder entfernen davon
jetzt sofort ok ich meine wir könnten winnows color picker in die vm also die 3m color picker
was gibt's was gibt's für einen guten firefox color picker color picker was ist das fage
ok das brauche ich fage
geht das geht das unter i3 if you use x color picker ok ok den benutzen wir von excellent
ist ja seht ihr mal für manche sachen sind nur linux gar nicht so einfach hallo was ist
das problem color picker ja welcher color picker davon ist der richtige click on a pixel on
your screen das scheint der richtige zu sein einfach schnell ein ruby programmieren ich
hätte euch das erzählen soll color wo ist er da ist er ok das scheint zu funktionieren
warum ist das jetzt nicht bei meinen programm zum starten drin alter das kann jetzt nicht
euer ernst sein dass ich das jetzt über das terminal starten soll dass ich das nicht als
normale desktop anwendung registriert hat oder ok also was ich machen wollte ich wollte
mit den color pick den hier picken und jetzt in dem in dem craft den keks mund color verwenden
für den craft das doch nice oder so muss das sein und ich hab mir auch überlegt ob
wir nicht die alerts ob wir nicht die alerts auch in so einer farbe machen alerts ja alert
nicht verfügbar color kein preis bild ändern ja das müssen wir noch machen ich meine das
hat ein bisschen besseren kontrast aber jetzt so viel besser ist bin ich mir nicht so sicher
zumal an dem keks nix grünes ist das sieht kacke aus
für nicht verfügbar keckweight ersetzen ne nicht verfügbar zeigt der da drin gar nicht
an wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so wir wollen die
Leute nicht zu sehr verwirren so notifications geht immer noch wunderbar ok kein preis haben
wir hier angezeigt also da gehen wir nochmal in dialog avatar so das können wir zumindest
mal einbauen also wenn ja ja das jetzt ein bisschen viel kacke weh if preis kleiner null
wobei was mache ich denn warum kopiere ich denn das ganze reicht auch wenn ich das image
wenn ich das auf dem image mache reicht auch wenn ich das auf dem image mache ich muss
doch gar nicht das ganze ding hallo ich will es hier copy pasten alert sound muss den browser
ändern das kannst du da nicht machen so jetzt kacke weight das wird nice ok ffz kacke weight
ist auch in groß aber immer angst wenn ich auf google bilder suche gehe dass da irgendwas
falsch rum falsch rum leute das ist nice das gefällt mir ich kann sound auf einer seite
abspielen das funktioniert mobile nicht und das mag eigentlich keiner wenn die seite irgendwelche
sounds abspielt macht das lieber über die notifications ich weil oder how to play sound
und website ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht also man muss jetzt hinterlegen und dann einfach
play ok der sound kommt ja nur wenn du notifications angemacht hast aber ganz ehrlich das braucht
man nicht die desktop notifications machen auch ein bimm und da kann es jeder einstellen
eigentlich eigentlich ist das sinniger ich glaube wir bauen noch keinen sound ein ok
kacke weight so wir schreiben jetzt noch hier hinter das popup bevor ich das pushe und ihr
das ausprobieren könnt hinter das popup schreibe ich jetzt noch in arbeit dass man weiß dass
es noch nicht funktioniert aber ich finde sie schon mal cool aus platzhalter so alles
klar so was müssen wir jetzt noch machen lassen wir überlegen ach ja ich habe eine
sache könnte man noch echt cool machen hier oben da zeigt jetzt überall so eine gpu an
wir könnten es dynamisch machen dass der gpu anzeigt und bei der konsole dass da bei der
konsole sogar anzeigt eine konsole halt ne oder zumindest irgendwas was so ähnlich aussieht
wie eine konsole gibt es da gibt es dann schönes bild für konsole controller oder sowas ja
an die konsole controller ja dann zeigen wir so gamepad an super nintendo wo es ist eine
mischung aus dem super nintendo dem ns controller moment stadia gibt es ein stadia icon da
seht ihr mal die kacke google selber stadia findet die hat noch nicht mal ein stadia icon
gemacht wenn die digger sind von google plus ein paar community addons aber zum größten
teil ist es google also es gibt kein xbox control das macht nichts die kriegen gleich
ein controller so das müssen wir jetzt bloß noch mal einstellen dass es auch tut erst
einmal müssen wir hier unsere übrigens unsere beschreibung fixen die stimmt ja nur für
grafikkarten also wie heißen die reisen dinger richtig amd reisen hier ist die richtige bezeichnung
von den dinger amd reisen alter lass mich copy so so so heißt es richtig amd reisen
5 5600 so sagt mir wenn ich misst machen der hier heißt wahrscheinlich genauso mit 8000
und der heißt wahrscheinlich genauso mit 9000 und der heißt wahrscheinlich genauso mit
9050 der heißt nicht x oder der heißt 9 der heißt der heißt wirklich 5950 ohne x vergessen
wo ist nix wo ist nix wo muss nix hin echt ich
x x
was sind das jetzt eigentlich für einer das sind siebener oder was das ist auch wieder
ein x dahinter das ist ein 7 7 x und das ist nun 9 x und ist das auch den neuen x oder
ist das einfach nur ohne x letztes auch x alles klar excellent so und die dinger heißen
dann so amd ich glaube so heißt wenn man ganz ganz
korrekt ist so so und der hier wahrscheinlich ohne xt und der hier mit 9 xt so sony gut das
ist einfach sony plays ich kann immer schreiben plastics playstation 5 das schreibt man glaube
ich zusammen playstation 5 wie nennt man die classic wie heißt die heißt die classic edition
classic das da unten ist digital edition digital auf die xbox das habe ich jetzt keinen
bock ich glaube ich glaube die dinger heißen auch tatsächlich einfach nur so nur noch
das microsoft davor kommt x ok jetzt haben wir das ganze in schön müsste es das pop
up schon mal funktionieren sehr gut habt ihr gesehen wie dynamisch er das abgedatet hat
classic guck mal da macht sogar man darf es nicht zu klein machen seht ihr mal wie clever
der sogar ist und da punkte hinten dran macht wenn es nicht ausreicht nicki 9208 dankeschön
für den sub großes playstation die sind ja hardcore drauf die leute da bei sony kann
es doch keiner merken so alles klar sehr schön sehr schön so jetzt sieht das pop up schön
aus ja oh guck mal computer universe klitscht in da rein wenn man nicht aufpasst anzeige
ist raus direkt also gut wunderbar so jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken dass der hier
oben das richtige anzeigt das heißt wir müssen das wir müssen das hinten bisschen erweitern
wir brauchen hier noch sowas wie also entweder machen wir jetzt direkt das emoji rein was
wir für den den den den das symbol rein oder wir schreiben hier sowas wie type ach komm
wir machen direkt das symbol an scheiß warum soll ich das im frontend noch mal extra matchen
ist doch komplett komplett bescheuert wo sind meine icons also das gibt gpu beziehungsweise
extension card oder so hieß das glaube die seite ist auch hardcore langsam kann man da
eins für eine die die mit die extension also icon sieht richtig champig aus ja so das ist
auch gpu seht ihr mal wie clever das ding ist guck mal da macht für mich ein kommer
hinten dran das sind auch gpus das nicht das sind auch wieder welche so cpu hatten die
hatten auch cpu hatten sie auch so und jetzt dann ich schöne das processor ich nehme halt
den meinetwegen wenn es sein muss was witzig ist intel ist mittlerweile so irrelevant dass
noch nicht mal im preis champ drin stehen cip cip was genau cip der da ne das ist memory
aber ich finde sieht aus wie cpu ach wir nehmen das mit 64 das doch wir gucken dann mal ob
das live updaten kann der sollte das nämlich live updaten wenn ich das dann ändere im
hintergrund ok jetzt haben wir das hier alles drin stehen und jetzt brauchen wir noch controller
controller
jetzt wim shortcuts ok hammer so dass das jetzt funktioniert muss ich auch mein typ erweitern
wenn ich wüsste wenn ich mich noch dran erinnern könnte wo ich den kram hin gepappt hab product
series genau das hat jetzt nicht das hat auch noch ein icon sehr gut so warten bis restartet
ist nehm den xbox controller es gibt keinen xbox controller oder gibt es den xbox controller
du meinst den da ach guck mal das ist ein stadia controller die gibt es tatsächlich
findest du nur nicht unter stadia ok es gibt tatsächlich einen xbox controller aber es
gibt kein xbox controller outline gibt es kein xbox controller outline das ist ziemlich
doof die outline varianten sehen viel cooler aus das können wir gleich mal live ändern
während es läuft dann können wir schauen dass das auch funzt ok das heißt wir zeigen
jetzt hier oben nicht immer expansion card an sondern wir zeigen an serious icon hier
warum hack wait marifreschen marifreschen muss mal kurz mal kurz hier die debug stels
aufmachen macht das auch so dass ihr was seht chat aha wo kommt man den scheiß noch mal
verschieben wo ist das wo ist das icon wo ist das ding zum verschieben von ihr ne das
war das wollte ich gar nicht das wollte ich btf so
man ist ja auch das falsche ist ja auch das falsche muss ich hier nachgucken im main datei
muss ich das nachgucken ja da wird es ja schon die ganze zeit raus gedammt warum ist hier
das icon nicht da ich habe es im craftql nicht abgefragt kann das sein icon da ist es doch
zack guck mal da bisschen fett würde ich sagen aber xbox also das funst und für die
grafika der extension geht auch habe ich mich hier verschrieben ich habe mdi vergessen
guck mal pass mal auf der sollte das eigentlich live updaten wenn ich das hat schon gemacht
ok sehr gut die ryzen cpu ist ein bisschen fett aber sieht eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht
aus oder so und jetzt und jetzt updaten wir das mal live was haben wir hier auf der 5800x
und da haben wir jetzt einfach mdi chip draus und da sollte das quasi on the fly ne das
ist nicht so reactive wie ich mir das gedacht habe da muss man halt neu laden es gibt schlimmeres
aber aber das dynamische hinzufügen funst noch oder oder habe ich das irgendwie geprägt
ne das funktioniert noch also hier xbox hier ist xs confirmed ok nice excellent excellent
so dann würde ich das mal pushen da können wir es ausprobieren
gucken ob es auch funktioniert guck da lieferbar rx ok wir pushen mal den preiszamp jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt mal gucken ob die russischen dedos tippen wieder am start sind jetzt mal
ein grefana dashboard aufmachen ach komm mal hier war ein aussetzer hier hier wirds
hier wirds schonmal gel gel guck mal da war ein aussetzer sag mal kann das sein dass ich
dass ich nicht gededost werde sondern hetzner um die urzeit ein paar probleme hat weil das
sind immer guck mal leute das ist immer die gleiche urzeit ne das das vielleicht werde
ich gar nicht gededost kakwait ich hab mich schon gefreut dass ich das das das so beliebt
ist dass ich gededost werde ok wir sehens gleich ich lock mich jetzt ein ich lock mich
jetzt ein mal gucken mal gucken wie gut es läuft attach achso moment kann ich da überhaupt
hin pushen jetzt ok kakwait ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich da ob ich da überhaupt
hin pushen kann ok ich muss erstmal auf jeden fall neues frontend bilden ok leute hab ich
schon irgendwas vergessen ich will jetzt nicht dass es kaputt geht wenn ichs pushe ähm
kann aber alles zu funsten erstmal ne was nice wäre wenns vielleicht ein paar von euch
auf dem android und auf dem iphone wobei im iphone kann ich selbst ausprobieren ob da
alles ordentlich scaled skaliert ok alles erden git add git commit a minus m streamsorts
push ähm ach du scheiße ähm was hat ich denn da nochmal genommen ich hab sonst einfach
key-authentifizierung ok das ist bei mir lokal daheim das ist egal admin admin ne ne
warte mal probier mal ich hab ich hab normalerweise nehme ich ja immer so einen schwachsinn aber
ich da hab ich da hab ich glaube ich was nicht super kompliziert ist aber was doch ein bisschen
längeres genommen das ist lokal domain bei mir na gut ist egal ich muss ja da auch gar
nicht hin pushen ich muss ja auf meinen server pushen das reicht ähm aber hier kurz das
ding aus das ach das doch von gestern auf dem server hier oder was ok dann gucken wir
mal wobei ich müsste jetzt ja eigentlich einfach das ding als remote adden können
wenn ich das noch richtig aus dem kopf geht remote add ähm preisschamp oh wie war die
syntax dafür äh natürlich als root als was sonst beta bezeit ich mal ein paar github
actions oder irgendwie sowas mach da kann ich einfach git pushen nach github auch in
private repo ist egal und es funktioniert einfach ok ich hoffe ich hab das richtig gemacht
jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich jetzt geht kurz der preisschamp kaputt preisschamp shut down
wie kann man ordnung auf seinem c halten äh downloads einfach auf eine andere andere ähm
andere platte machen hab ich auch ich hab ja nur eine 512 g ssd drin und da kommen ein
paar einzelne spiele drauf aber ich hab noch eine zweite 2 terabyte ssd und noch eine äh
6 terabyte platte dran und das passt eigentlich und dann hab ich die downloads hab ich auf
der magnet festplatte alter beende dich mal der preisschamp will nicht so mal gucken was
macht der preisschamp wow der überträgt ganz schön viel
komm mal der preisschamp der will gar nicht mehr abbrechen preisschamp paper please könntest
du was zu deinem system in der vm sagen erklären ja aber er ist noch nicht beendet ist der
preisschamp der preisschamp ist weg oder ok der preisschamp ist ist ist wohl weg wo ist
das alter wo ist das problem beende dich mal ähm könntest du was zu deinem system in der
vm sagen das ist mein charo mit die 3 wm alter ich kill das jetzt gleich
der preisschamp hängt aber ganz schön hart ok leute jetzt ah jetzt vielleicht jetzt vielleicht
preisschamp preisschamp geh aus ansonsten wenn du nicht brav bist preisschamp dann weißt
du was passiert der preisschamp will sie nicht beenden weiß ich weiß ich gesagt gar nicht
warum die rammer haben wir eigentlich gerade so ok preisschamp 5 4 3 2 1 ok repp preisschamp
hat sich ausgezämmt jetzt hängt er wieder leute kann das sein dass der einfach nur ewig
lange braucht bis zur verbindung weil guck mal jetzt hängt wieder ich glaube das sind
gar keine russischen denos dudes oder so der preisschamp hat irgendwie probleme beim verbindung
schließen oder so könnte das sein programmierst du den preisschamp aus spaß ja hauptsächlich
unfalls was bringt kann das sein dass der preisschamp ein bisschen irgendwie linux
netzwerk mäßig probleme macht oder kann es sein dass der preisschamp weil da so viele
connections closed die hetsen der dedos protection triggert oder irgendwie sowas dann guck mal
hier der macht dann der macht schon ein bisschen was der ganze chat ist eingeloggt oh nee
warum alter warum ist der server auf einmal so am rumspacken wo ist das problem das sind
16 kerne und das ding macht faktisch nix ganz die ganze welt ist lockt in da preisschamp
ist total aber warum hä das verstehe ich nicht das leuchtet mir echt nicht ein warum
der so am abkacken ist dabei jetzt der pinkt auch nicht mehr wahnsinn okay dann dann glaube
ich doch nicht dass ich gededost werde ich habe ich hatte ja so die vermutung aber aber
wie kann das sein was macht er irgendwie 30 aber selbst wenn er 30.000 verbindung beendet
wo ist das problem ich habe ich will mich jetzt nicht bei hetsen einloggen da muss man
smartphone holen für otp hast du geguckt ob das ding am brennen ist naja wenn schon brennt
bei hetsen im rechenzentrum und es ist eine vm nee also warum der so am abkacken ist verstehe
ich nicht kann es sein dass bei einer registrierten notification der server ständig abgefragt
wird wenn er nicht antwortet ja aber selbst wenn dann machen die paar besucher die da
drauf sind auch nicht den server dauen ich verstehe das verstehe nicht ich muss mal kurz
hier ausmachen mal kurz und dann gehe ich mal ich logg mich mal bei hetsen ein wird
Zeit dass ich das aufsplitte leute morgen splitt ich das auf dass das stört dass der
scrawler ding so otp muss die muss die autentifizierung app
aufmachen immer so ein akt sich da einzuloggen aber so ist das halt bequemlichkeit versus
security ne okay ich bin eingeloggt okay gut dann machen wir die vm wieder an ich mach
die fall immer aus dass nix über den clipboard manager landet an passwörtern und so oder
war noch nicht ganz tot er hat kurz geantwortet er hat kurz geantwortet der preis jump
alles vorbei
okay ich starte jetzt neu über die über die konsole er hat wieder geantwortet leute
hat wieder er hat wieder geantwortet er antwortet schon wieder was ist jetzt fängt er sich
noch mal fängt er sich noch mal postchamp er will nicht er will nicht disabelt werden
er will nicht er will nicht rebooted werden naja wenn du cloudflare davor machst wieder
auf irgendeine hetsnerkiste ne leute ist vorbei ist vorbei ich starte jetzt neu ist aus und
jetzt mache ich wieder an
dabei guck mal der leckt sogar dabei
seht ihr das okay wie gesagt ich glaube nicht mehr an den russischen dedos sondern dass
dass irgendwas anderes da nicht stimmt guck mal hier 300 leute pingen an das juckt überhaupt
nicht ob 300 leute an pingen 300 leute pingen ist vollkommen egal
kann man kann man das rechenzentrum verschieben bei hetsner irgendwie
geht nicht ja gut dann müssen wir warten bis er jetzt wieder bis er sich wieder gefangen
hat er ich mein ich mein er pinkt ja zumindest schon mal ein bisschen wieder zwar nicht oft
aber aber ab und zu ab und zu pinkt aber wie kann das sein dass es nach dem reboot immer
noch probleme gibt es gibt doch überhaupt keinen sinn aber erst mal das ganze andere
zeug zu rippe price jam sicher dass er dauernd war er ich habe ausgeschaltet wieder angemacht
dass hier abteilen drin steht das hat nichts zu sagen da konnte einfach noch nicht weiter
abfragen guck mal hier cpu wie das raufgegangen ist jetzt hat er keine datmen er konnte einfach
nur nichts abfragen in der zwischenzeit sag mal hetsner datacenter es war übelst am abkacken
aber das verstehe ich aber guck mal hat er sich eingekriegt ist er ist der russische
dados vorbei jetzt hängt es wieder also das sind so merkwürdige sachen so so random so
unerklärliche hänger die sollten eigentlich nicht aufdrehen deswegen war ja auch meine
erste vermutung irgendeiner hat sich da sein russisches spotnetz am start oder was auch
immer den pranz guck es euch mal an das ist doch definitiv nicht normal der server steht
in nürnberg oder so nürnberg ja schön mittler da musst du nicht glaube der macht ja nix
ich weiß ja auch nicht was der für schmerzen hat ehrlich gesagt so jetzt pushen wir erstmal
den preisschamp push auf preisschamp und da will ich allerdings den beta branch pushen
verkehrt kommt an die hett ist ja groß
könnte das sein dass das irgendeine hetsner dedos protection ist dass das aus irgendwelchen
gründen der 50.000 verbindungen zu macht und dann die hetsner dedos protection irgendwie
meint oder stimmt was nicht weil ich glaube nicht wirklich dass ernsthaft irgendjemand
nix hier im stream sitzt und da ding wie dedos oder das ergibt eigentlich wenig sinn wird
mich nicht wohl ja man weiß es ist aber komisch es ist immer nur im stream so wir haben gepusht
ja selbst hatte hier auch nicht viel network disk hat er hat er packages per second drin
network traffic bei packets komm mal der hat der hat einfach mal 100.000 100.000 packages
per second so will transmit als auch receive und ihr seht das ist den ganzen tag über
12 stunden den ganzen tag über ist nix das ist nur wenn man nur wenn man im stream on
ist schon merkwürdig oder schon schon merkwürdig arbeitest du auch untertags dran ich glaube
ich habe das noch nicht ausgeschaltet untertags aber ich mache den ich wie gesagt ich mache
das hinter cloud flair sobald das jetzt läuft dann ok also check out beta dot net run so
wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe sollte der preisschamp demnächst mit an der
preisschamp kann es kann wieder nicht erreichbar ok ist ja gut warum hast du bei cloud flair
eine dsg voklage am hals cloud flair verwendet so gut wie jeder da ist er es hat jetzt über
15 minuten gedauert lull so poggers street merchant und jetzt start wie alt ich bin 36
so jeder preisschamp sieht schon mal ganz gut aus dass mit den mit den grafen sieht auch
ok aus jetzt muss nur noch jetzt muss nur noch der tracker starten dann passt das alles
voll alt ja ich sag es doch die leute klauen mit jetzt immer noch die sagen dass da max
du bist du hörst dich so an wie 20 das ist ja nice aber bin ich nicht oder preisschamp
hängt wieder wolltest du nicht den tracker im docker laufen lassen nee ich werde das
front an dem docker laufen lassen und ich also ich habe es mir so überlegt ich werde
mir den also hetzner pricing ich zeige euch mal was wir da machen cloud pricing also was
ich mir überlegt habe weiße so ich hole mir so ein ding so ein ding fürs für für den
crawler acht kerne reicht ist ok dann hole ich mir so ein ding hier oder so oder wahrscheinlich
hole ich mir erstmal so ein ding fürs front end fertig da kommt dann cloud flair davor
und gut ist da mache ich ein internes netzwerk dazwischen kann man ja bei hetzner machen
dass quasi die beiden server inter noch mal im gleichen netz hängen und der publish dann
neueste sachen zum preisschamp ist schon gestartet er crawlt
und er crawlt ordentlich
so erste sache ist grün jawohl ne xbox guck mal bei otto deutscher autolan hat ne xbox
ja also wer schon leute ihr habt es im stream gesehen wer schon immer mal ne xbox series
s haben will für dass das die keiner haben will ist die erstaun oh keck wait oh nee der
preisschamp wird wieder die dorst ok dann gehen wir jetzt hier runter
welche seiten checken die ab so gut wie alle deutschen seiten checkt ihr ab mein factory
alternate otto art cyberport computer universe sonst was so man kann sich noch die not not
notifications dann schicken lassen sagst du hier zack will ich informiert werden gut
ist da muss jetzt natürlich erstmal sich wieder eine runde durchcrawlen wir gehen einfach
in die magenta cloud leute wir gucken mal was es kostet nein es ist compute wie heißt
es bei denen will kein speicher cloud server hier ok sollen sollen die grafen schon funktionieren
nein die grafen funktionieren nicht steht ja auch dahinter in arbeit die grafen funktionieren
noch nicht magenta cloud zu den tarifen also zeig mal was kostet sichern sie sich extra
viel nein ich will ein will kein speicher ich will ich will surfer haben haben die haben
die keine server zu mieten oder was ach das ist die open telekom cloud ok open telekom
cloud alles klar da also compute ich will einfach nur stink normalen poplischen popliche
vm gibts sowas hier nicht die haben sowas ok was kostet ein bare metal server erfolgreich
hinzugefügt und jetzt open linux alle haben die die haben doch nicht mal nur bunto oder
debian was redhead wer will so crap alter ich will einfach das ist mir zu dumm da checkt
es checkt doch keiner also was ich vor hab ist folgendes ich hol mir so ein achtkerner
machen internes netz dazwischen hier kommt das frontend drauf und der besucherzähler
und hier kommt der crawler drauf ein gutes 2k im monat ja ich weiß nicht was los ist
bei hetsner bezahlt ich für 16 kerne ok nicht dedicated aber dedicated cpu bezahlt
für 16 kerne 160 ich weiß nicht was mit der telekom los ist wer sich diesen kram überhaupt
geben will ja und den letzten letzten 15 minuten gucken wir mal das ist ja der hatte schon
ein bisschen was zu tun der gute hier 100.000 package per second kann das sein dass da drüber
aber 100.000 das klingt so glatt das klingt schon irgendwie nach das irgendwo was limitiert
wird connections 250.000 connections 250.000 connections ok das ist doch der russische
dedos am start das kann es das kann es anders da kann es nicht sein anders kann es das ergibt
eigentlich keinen sinn cloudflare floor and fair ja hab ich schon preisschamp orc ist
schon über über über things über cloudflare es ist halt dumm weil eigentlich wenn ich
hier im stream was mache dann will ich das nicht über den server mit cloudflare machen
weil sonst liegt ich im zweifelsfall noch die server ip dann muss die server ip erst
ändern bei cloudflare die floating ip bei hetsner hetsner hat doch der hätte sagen
sie haben dedos protection aber was auch immer interne connections oder externe das sieht
man nicht allerdings so viel interne connections kann das ja net net haben das ding hatte keinerlei
interne ip irgendwie und andere server cloudflare da vorn gut ist so aber leute der neue preisschamp
ist am start was sagt ihr ja exzellente da fehlt was warum zeigt der oh nee ich ich ich
hätte den russischen dedos nicht ansprechen sollen leute ich hätte nicht sagen sollen
wo wo wo wo wo sind die einträge da unten wo sind die einträge für die jeweiligen
sachen die er gefunden hat der zeigt gar nix an grad was ist das denn
okay der reisen an falsches eiken echt welcher der reisen 5800 ne hat doch passt doch das
stimmt ach nee das habe ich ausprobiert das habe ich ausprobiert aber wir können mal
gucken ob wir das live updaten können solange soll ich drauf kommen lull weh solange ich
drauf kommen ja guck der der der da brechen die verbindung weg ich jetzt kein bock mehr
etze hat in der klaut natürlich haben in der klaut eine konsole das bringt mir nur nix
also da kommt jetzt klautflare da vorn gut ist lustigerweise wenn ich den stream ausmache
beruhigt sich auch immer was sehr verdächtig ist weiß aber nicht warum also was der zweck
da jetzt von ist also ich meine es macht ja nix geht aber wieder
irgendwie spackt die anzeige rum was kostet der spaß klaut für nix klautflare kostet
da ist erstmal nix na gut leute das ist jetzt erstmal gepusht was willst du machen irgendwas
ist noch falsch der reisen war aber welcher reisen war falsch das grafana auf lull jaja
guck mal hier 5800 ist falsch ok excellent excellent
naja das muss schon einer sein wenn es einer wirklich steht was sollte dann ist das irgendjemand
im stream naja so also was machen wir jetzt noch klautflare mach ich einrichten kann ich
nicht im stream machen wenn ich klautflare einrichten im stream mache dann sind die
ips ja geleakt das ist ja nicht so sinnvoll aber ich mache das morgen danach im aufwachen
stream wobei nee ich mache das jetzt glaube ich noch pw a draus zu machen ist easy ich
mache das jetzt noch weil dann hat das dns zeit beziehungsweise die namensauflösung
zeit sich auf klautflare umzustellen heute nacht das dauert ja immer ein paar stunden
bis das bei allen so ist bis der cash überall weg ist also vielleicht stelle ich jetzt doch
noch auf klautflare die kiste um ich meine ich muss die ip vorher ändern ip ist ja schon
milliardenfach geleakt hier einfach neue ip dran hängen und dann klautflare anschalten
da kann sich das heute nacht propagaten die dns geschichte so ich gucke jetzt mal subscribers
weil ich glaube ich habe die hälfte wieder nicht gesehen starte noch mal kurz lokal bin
ich bin ich bei github eingeloggt ah nee sonst hätten wir vielleicht mal github github
actions machen können dafür also der emko hat gesagt ja ich habe es nicht gesehen ich
habe das mit dem video nicht vergessen ich hatte den ganzen tag keine zeit ich habe
noch nicht mal ins discord geguckt falls du geantwortet hast aber also wir machen das
ja ich habe es nicht gesehen dass du gesagt hast danke für den zap huge chat iq wieder
monopole hat abonniert dankeschön exzellenz
nicki 9208 prime subscription ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr alle noch da seid ich hoffe mal
jetzt wo ich vorlese dass auch ein paar im start sind es war nur der name frei dankeschön
für den sap ob das habe ich schon gesehen die ganzen aussetzer hier
also das hat schon sehr auffällig wenn ich hier auf einmal 100 7 267.000 connections
hast und es ist limit mehr geht nicht unterschiedliche gpu hersteller aber das funktioniert nicht
wirklich gut ich habe zwar die info aber der tracker enthält dafür zu wenig also der ist
ja teilweise schon nicht sonderlich up to date wenn es darum geht bei den das dauert
er teilweise eine ganze weile bis die neuen grafika hat ein paar neuen shops daneben klicken
da geht sich mal auf ha ha es ist verbuckt keck weight warum das können wir noch fixen
schnell ich weiß zwar nicht woran es liegt was wollte ich gerade sagen es hat mich jetzt
abgelenkt ja genau der track der tracker braucht teilweise schon so lang bis das überhaupt
gecheckt hat es geht wirklich nicht mit einem mit den einzelnen karten und die kommen da
nicht hinterher mit hersteller und und verschiedene modellen und so das hat glaube ich keinen
sinn das ist nie aktuell du musst zumachen durch hier oben so drauf dann geht es nicht
mehr dass das fixen wir noch schnell aber lokal jetzt hier repos docker ps läuft das
war das was nämlich laufen also woran könnte das denn liegen ich weiß woran es liegt ich
weiß es ist easy ich weiß woran es liegt wenn ich hier auf fack wie mache ich das jetzt
also wenn ich escape drücke sage ich klaus wenn ich darauf drücke sage ich klaus aber
wie ketsche ich das hat außen hingeklickt event um klaus zu zu machen
click outer ich habe keine ahnung click outside moment au outside click outside ernsthaft
gibt es sowas aber es müsste es müsste ein ad ad click outside sein stack overflow triffen
programming ich sage es euch beste fix easy so dann pushen wir das das noch mal so her
da so ich bin wieder auf meinem server drauf keck weh den aus engage wie noch nicht gut
da legen wir jetzt los wir können mal ein zweites git repo machen geht inne da können
wir das nämlich hierauf pushen während das läuft also das ist auch ein ding wo ich mich
mal hinsetzen muss das können wir auch am stream mal wir machen in github actions workflow
auf obs levels auf an 1000 wir machen in github actions workflow was das alles macht oder
noch cooler noch besser wie leute ich weiß was wir machen ich weiß was wir machen wir
machen den docker feil für die asp.net anwendung und dann benutzen wir die neue github github
container registry um das um das zu speichern und das checken wir uns dann aus im workflow
irgendwie sowas das richtig big brain logik machen wir dann und was macht der dedos immer
noch nicht enttäuschend enttäuschende so also dann pushen remote ad price champ 2 heißt
es jetzt excellent push push price champ 2 in branch beta jawoll in branch price champ
2 geht check out wunderbar cp die datenbank kopieren wir mal rüber und ja ich habe forst
noch beim letzten mal dran gemacht das ist immer witzig auf der arbeit sag ich immer
leute macht forst nicht standardmäßig rein jetzt kontrollieren wir mal was so ich mache
jetzt den price champ aus guck mal den price champ mal zu beim ausgehen ich verstehe halt
echt nicht warum der hängt bei mir lokal geht er auch easy aus überhaupt kein problem
ok ich kill den price champ wieder geht immer noch alles juckt juckt die nicht kein china
dedos am start wie groß ist die db ach nicht so groß 6,4 gigabyte und das schreibt schon
vier tage am stück kram darein jetzt bei euch was hier los leute es ist nicht gefixt
ach so wisst ihr warum es nicht gefixt ist lull weh ich hab ich hab nicht gepusht ich
hab mich ich hab mich committed ich hab mich committed aber gebildet hammer ok ok ok ok
wisst ihr was der price champ der wird jetzt immer gekillt weil er irgendwie nicht will
so wir hängen das jetzt einfach an ans letzte und gut ist push price champ ok und jetzt auf
gehts ne ne dotnet run so jetzt sollte es jetzt sollte es gleich funktionieren ok das
kam noch aus dem cash what the what the fuck what
wait was musst du nicht aus g2 starten ich hab es ins erste gepusht ich hab es ins erste
gepusht dialerates ok ok ok okafter
was ist es doch auch
Ich hab schon richtig gepusht.
Ok, Preischamp machen wir nochmal aus.
Killen.
Ähhh.
Ich hab's doch.
Also prinzipiell geht das doch.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Alles gut.
Doch alles committed. Mal ein Bild machen.
Woran könnte es das liegen, dass das jetzt nicht mehr aufgeht?
So Bild haben wir gemacht.
Push.
Preischamp.
Achso ich weiß woran es gelegen hat. Lull.
Ich bin im falschen Branch.
Es wird Zeit für den ultimativen Big Brain Death Ops Workflow hier, ich sag's euch.
Aha. Fixed Leute, fixed.
Asp.net Core mit Vue, ja genau.
Die coolen Leute, die würden das ja auch nicht auf zwei Hetsnetservern hausten, sondern die, also Leute, die die richtig im Trend sind, die würden, also erstens mal mindestens so wie ich das gemacht hätte, ein Backend Cloud Server, ein App Cloud Server, das ganze natürlich verdockerisiert und Netlify,
Netlify für, für das Frontend.
Also das wäre mal das Mindeste, was man als richtig, richtig hipper,
Bro Kramer 2021 so macht.
Ich habe mir jetzt übrigens bei Hetsna ein neues Projekt angelegt, das ich im Stream nichts mehr liege.
Das habe ich extra genannt Alarm, mit so einem Alarm Emoji, der ja nicht öffnen.
Netlify ist wirklich cool, ja.
Was hat Max vor Feasy gelernt? Stonks Zeug habe ich gelernt, daher kommt ja meine Abneigung zur BWL Kram.
So sieht ja normaler Traffic bei dem Ding aus, by the way.
Leute, iChill ist am Start, iChill x4 Inno3D.
So jetzt, jetzt lasse ich aber gut sein für heute, was die fixe Sachen angeht.
Ihr dürft euch jetzt am aktuellen Preis Champ erfreuen.
Du brauchst noch Easter Eggs, ich brauche erst mal alle Funktionen bevor ich Easter Eggs brauche.
Wobei, wisst ihr was ein geiles Easter Egg wäre?
Dass man irgendwo Dings abgespielt bekommt.
Das wirst du vielleicht wieder einbauen.
Guck mal Leute, wie es aktualisiert hier.
Ach guck mal, jetzt kann man sich gar nicht anzeigen lassen, was der rote.
Vielleicht soll ich dann wirklich eine Legende einblenden lassen.
Okay, aber das fixen wir heute nicht mehr online.
Jetzt machen wir nur mal lokal. Kann man da eine Legende einblenden lassen?
Äh Fletcher, vier Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wann postest du das auf Slashprogramm? Ich poste sowas prinzipiell nicht auf Reddit.
Generell sind Foren wenig hilfreich, wenn es um sowas geht.
Foren sind eher dafür da, Leute die neu anfangen zu verwirren.
Weil sie denen immer erklären wollen, so nach dem Motto.
In einem Forum fragt einer, wie mache ich eine Webseite mit zwei Bildern vom letzten Urlaub.
Das ist die Frage im Forum. Oder auf Reddit.
Und da kommt als Antwort, jetzt musst du erstmal Webpack lernen.
Dann musst du dir noch irgendein Frontend Framework angucken.
Nicht zu vergessen irgendwelche automatisierte Testing Suites.
Dann musst du noch Flask und Python lernen fürs Backend.
Und dann Svelte als Frontend noch dabei.
Die verwirren die Leute so extrem. Ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Oder wenn die dann anfangen. Was auch immer geil ist, wenn es eine.NET Geschichte ist.
Die Leute fragen so nach dem Motto, wie filtre ich aus irgendeine Schulaufgabe.
Wie filtre ich aus dem Array Elemente größer fünf raus.
Was der Typ braucht ist, dass ihm einer sagt, an der Stelle nimmst du einen For Each.
An der Stelle nimmst du einen Four. Das braucht er.
Und die Leute schicken ihm dann so einen Link Query.
Fünf Seiten lang ist Link Query und sagen, so gehts.
Da kommt jetzt exakt raus, was du brauchst.
Der Typ hat keinen Blasenschimmer, was der da eigentlich gerade liest.
Und natürlich nicht zu vergessen, ohne Strukturam und UML Diagramm kannst du eh nix machen.
Das haben wir ja in der Schule so gelernt.
Ich hoffe ihr macht das auch alle so, wie man das immer lernt.
Als erstes mal ein UML Diagramm und ein Strukturam machen.
Macht ihr das auch so?
Also wenn ihr das nicht so macht, dann zweifle ich an euren professionellen Developer Skills.
Ein Papp, ein Papp auch noch davor.
Ein Papp muss auch noch sein.
Und ganz wichtig ein Ishikawa Diagramm.
Wisst ihr was ein Ishikawa Diagramm ist?
Ist auch ganz ganz wichtig.
Das muss man auch vorher machen.
Weg damit.
Leute, fuck, jetzt hab ich voll verdrängt, was soll ich jetzt machen.
Ich hab gesagt wir fixen das nicht mehr online, sondern...
Ihr müsst mir heben, mein Boomer hier leckt.
Legende vom Chart, genau.
Hat der Preis-Champ schon ein paar Einträge?
Warum hat der Preis-Champ noch keine Einträge?
Oh.
Nein, es läuft nicht.
Nein, nein, ich bin nicht geplogged.
Das ist die List.
Das ist das Ding, was dieser Docker-Container abrufen will.
Ich weiß, von GitHub-Dings.
Warum geht das nicht?
Da kann er nicht starten, wenn das nicht abrufbar ist.
Das sackt.
Ist doch abrufbar.
Kegweight-Docker.
So, Legende.
Weil ich brauch erstmal was, wo was...
Wobei ich kann es auch so mit der Legende machen.
Also Chart, Legende, hier.
Legend, Legend gleich True.
Alles klar.
Kann man das nicht unten machen?
Das sieht da...
Äh.
Onker-S.
Das sieht scheiße aus mit der Legende.
Oder?
Warum kann das nicht so eine Grafana-Legende machen?
So ein großes Ding ist UVP.
Ach, die Leute sind nicht dumm.
Die erkennen, dass das UVP ist.
Nur zwei Punkte und an der Seite einladen.
Ja, das funktioniert leider nicht.
Man kann nur die Punkte komplett ausmachen.
Wenn ich nämlich sowas hier mache,
der kann es nicht erweitern von einem Datenpunkt zunächst.
Da hab ich plus von Sonntag bis Montag.
Ach, Moment.
Wenn man weiß, wo man drüber gehen muss, dann...
Äh.
Das findet doch niemand.
Das findet doch legit keiner.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich mehr Einträge mache,
als da steht?
Hör mal auf.
Was ist das hier?
Warum macht er da nicht mehr Punkte?
Leute, was ist ein gutes Chart-Framework für JavaScript?
Das ist Chart.js.
Ich hab mal Am-Charts verwendet vor einem Jahr oder so.
Auf der Y-Achse stehen viel zu große Werte.
Wieso?
Stimmt doch.
2500 Euro, 0 Euro.
Geh mal auf eine andere Karte.
Ja, und das ist immer der gleiche Graph.
Das ist immer der gleiche Graph.
Falls du nicht gemerkt hast, der Graph ändert sich nicht.
Ist immer der gleiche Graph.
Deswegen steht ihr da auch in Arbeit dahinter.
Aber die Legende ist kacke.
Was hat man da für Optionen für Legende?
Top, left, bottom.
Okay, okay.
Wie macht man das?
Wow.
Ach, wisst ihr was?
Das passt schon.
Kann man Point-Radius eins machen?
Komm mal, so lasst mal das.
Da können die Leute draufklicken und erkennen, dass das UVP gut ist.
Oder wir machen einfach Größe 60.
Und dann ist es easy, dann findet man es überall.
Kann man das hoch machen?
Point-Radius 10.
Bäm.
Voll beschissen aus.
0W.
Camping macht es gut.
So, so lasse ich das jetzt.
Reicht.
So.
Ähm.
Hat sich der Preis-Cham selbst wieder eingependelt?
Jawohl, geht alles.
PC King hat was am Start.
So, gucken wir mal auf den Preis-Cham drauf.
Was gibt es hier Neues?
Schönes.
Komm mal hier, fast alles verfügbar.
Seht ihr mal, Leute.
Unsere Seite hat funktioniert.
Das, wir haben doch, wir haben doch die, wir haben das doch geadded, die 6900.
Das ist die, die wir vorhin geadded haben.
Gibt es nur auf Alternate.
Es, also man muss ja sagen, das Pop-Up sieht ein bisschen kacke aus, wenn da nur ein Shop
drin steht.
Vielleicht sollte man das noch in die Mitte machen, wenn da nur ein Shop drin ist.
By the way, Docker, was ist das Problem hier gerade?
Was ist eigentlich mit einem Dark Mode?
Ah, Dark Mode ist eine coole Idee.
Dark Mode ist auch easy umzusetzen.
Das machen wir noch.
Mir ist eh langweilig.
Ich bin echt nicht richtig müde heute.
Ähm.
Jetzt crawlt er.
Im Docker hat er vorher nicht gecrawlt.
Jetzt habe ich aber wieder 100% CPU-Auslastung, Lokal Null.
Nee, ich, ich, das, das Dark Mode machen wir noch schnell.
Das geht nämlich wirklich sehr, sehr zackig.
Ist nur die Frage, wo wir das hinmachen.
Kann, kann man das nicht zentrieren?
Kann man nicht?
Moment, das, guck mal, wie's geht jetzt.
Line-Shot nehmen wir noch mal.
Äh, wenn nur eins da ist.
Sprit.
Ja.
Aber wie, aber das war doch richtig.
Jetzt muss ich die Kram nur noch zentrieren.
Aber dann ist es nicht mehr, aber dann ist es nicht mehr so cool responsive, wenn ich das wegmache.
Ach komm.
Wir werden's überleben.
Und so, so schlimm sieht's jetzt anders aus.
Ist halt dann nur ein Ding.
Hängt halt ein bisschen links in der Ecke, aber okay.
Okay, also, Dark Seam ist total einfach zu konfigurieren.
Muss ich mir aber trotzdem mal abgucken, weil falsch, der weiß, wie's funktioniert.
Aber es ist einfach.
Und danach gehen wir ins Bett.
Ja, also da muss man die config.
Ja.
Seam Dark True.
Und zack, ist Dark Seamed.
Jetzt muss man nur noch einen Schalter einbauen.
Und das sieht Dark auch gar nicht so übel aus.
So, das guck ich mir jetzt einfach ab.
Wo, wo hab ich hier meinen Seam Switcher drin?
Home?
Moment, hatte ich das da überhaupt, hatte ich überhaupt den Monarch Essen Seam Switcher?
Ah nee, das ist standardmäßig Dark.
Nee, ich mach, die Boomer, die wollen das nicht auf standardmäßig Dark.
Ich glaub, man kann aber einfach setzen.
Ich glaub, das war ziemlich easy.
Man musste sagen, irgendwie, this Beautify Theme Dark gleich True oder so.
Ah, easy, das war's.
Genau, siehst du, aus dem Kopf.
Oder auch nicht.
Doch, aus dem Kopf.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir nur noch einen Knopf.
Wo machen, wo könnte man da einen guten Knopf hin machen für Dark Seamed?
Ob rechts?
Irgendwo hier so?
Ob links, ob rechts?
Ja, also, VBTN, Icon.
So, MDE idea ist glaub ich die Lampe, ne?
Ok, das kann, warum kann ich mir diese Material Design Icons nicht merken?
Auf den Keks klicken.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Ey, das ist eine geile Idee.
Man kann es ja zusätzlich machen.
So, jetzt hätten wir noch einen Icon da oben mit Button.
Aber wir machen auf den Keks klicken, das finde ich jetzt eine coole Idee.
Aus Versehen auf den Keks geklickt, blind.
Toggle Sieme.
Das Sieme toggeln wir.
So, wo sind wir hier?
Dark Seamed, wo sind wir, wo sind wir?
Da, ich hab's.
Bin es schon wieder nicht mehr.
Mounted, irgendwo in Mounted.
Ah, ich kacke nur, hab's gelöscht.
Wenn man da drauf kommt, der Keg W Sound, das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Excellent Switch.
Das ist die faulste Variante für einen Switch, der mir jetzt eingefallen ist.
Okay.
Ach, Moment, was mache ich da für einen Blödsinn?
Klick.
Ich toggle Sie.
Lull.
Zu spät.
Zack.
Wisst ihr, was jetzt noch cool wäre?
Wenn wir den Keks mit einer Sonnenbrille hätten.
Wir haben doch Woop Prime, der hat doch eine Sonnenbrille auf.
Woop.
Our
Copy, Image, Adress, ah nee, den hab ich erst.
Woop Prime würde mega gut passen, ja.
Mein Problem ist nur, haben wir noch einen Mod am Start, der zufällig einen Link hat
zu dem Emote in High Res.
Ich habe das auf dem account nicht wo erziehst du die preise da von von allen möglichen shop seiten
mordcheck mordcheck alles schon weg
ja wo kriege ich meine eigenen emotes jetzt her
gab sich twitch emotes search die seite online ja hier kannst du ausprobieren
beta punkt preisschirm punkt org
twitch emotes search ja
dann haben wir prime aber drauf wenn es wenn es dark ist eigentlich richtig cool
warte mal ich habe eine idee ich mal kurz ausblenden
starte mal kurz admin admin fenster ich darf nicht darauf zugreifen na geil
darf ich nicht mal als admin drauf zugreifen keck weh das denn users da habe ich doch
ok
wie kopiert man was in der winnaus cmd leute copy cp weiß ich wie das geht wie kopiert man
der winnaus cmd alter ich kann nicht rechtstück machen das ist kommandos sein fenster nein ich
meine datei kopieren datei kopieren cmd copy file gehen das x copy kann man nicht einfach
eine datei kopieren unter winnaus einfach copy ok copy
wub boom wub leak wub old wub pock wub prime wub prime will ich kopieren
nach c doppelpunkt users stream so hat er das jetzt kopiert
ok easy ich kann euch wieder einblenden was ein act so ein kram zu kopieren ok jetzt hat
es twitch emote schon gefahren jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich schon kopiert wub prime da
ist es muss den kram nur noch kurz die vm in die vm kopieren
kopieren wir den kram mal kurz rein wub prime zack und jetzt wub prime in assets alles klar
da sind wir am start wub prime so also klick klick ist das so source müsste doch eigentlich
auch so gehen source wenn das dark dann hoffe das funst weil ich da mache dann das und wenn
ansonsten erstmal gucken ob es prinzipiell geht ah Mist ok ok das dynamisch machen geht
sieht schonmal nett ich erwarte dass das geht wenn if else können wir machen ne ok das
funktioniert nicht source dann ups jetzt habe ich komplett kaputt gemacht lull achso ok
guck mal was der flow in oben geschrieben hat hat er denn geschrieben
agile microservices hat er geschrieben so dann machen wir sowas jetzt hier if u if wenn
das nicht dark ist dann das weil das ist ja das normale und das andere ist u else wub
prime
ich glaube das hat er nicht gecheckt sehr gut das ist ja cool oder erst pockt er erst
pockt er und im dunklen hat er hat er easy money easy life das finde ich richtig nice
das gefällt mir dark reader brauchen wir nicht wir haben net native dark dark theme
das ist sogar halbwegs gut lesbar dark das dark theme braucht vielleicht noch ein paar
optimierungen alles gut erkennbar ist da nicht aber hauptsache asus hat keck keck weight
drinne hauptsache asus hat keck weight weil kein preis ja das das passt sich leider nicht
an dark theme an in 45 min nur hast du gewürzter ja schau alles cool aber so lang bleib ich
die katze war an der tür preis unter uvp ja wunsch denken der punkt ist viel zu klein
und auch so fett man
das noch so machen das diagramm sieht schon ein bisschen räudig schlecht aus oder weil
es hier ein loch hat vorne und hinten warum warum hat das warum hat das hier so ein ding
also leute jetzt ins bett gehen wir sehen uns dann guck mal hier wie das sieht cool aus
wie er das aktualisiert ja leute soll ich noch soll ich noch schnell den preis champ
mit neuen mit neuen bildern pushen mit dark theme kommen das machen wir jetzt noch schnell
erkannte kann er da kann der dedos du sich noch mal dann auslassen lokal kann ich das
doch auch quitten wo ist das problem ja es war ich gehe gleich gleich auf ich push jetzt
noch das ding hier und dann ist gut
das löst er da alles
der wird schon der wird schon wissen was er macht erst mal schön anhängen so mit der
killen check out was da ist ja nicht ganz so opti optimaler workflow check out beta release
ist der preis champ wieder am start die musik eigentlich ist das relaxen kirby music oder
so was stand da doch dran ane happy happy und epic nicht relaxen
beim leute du musst mal refreshen du musst mal refreshen ohne ohne cash dann gehts bestimmt
bei dir auch nice ok leute viel spaß mit dem preis champ
heute nacht ich gehe jetzt auf gepen noch einmal für alle die schon länger dabei sind
die übliche outro musik die habe ich die letzte zeit etwas vernachlässigt wir sehen
uns leute bis denn see you